welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Marvel Studios still has a huge
opportunity to explore story lines in
the most interesting period of MCU
history the black looking scenes 2 is
now rumored to show mobius's jet ski
selling origin to be during the years
that Thanos had dusted half of all life
out of the universe which I love to hear
not just because it aligns with
rensslayer's origin as a high school
principle during this period but it
finally sounds like Marvel might be
tapping into what I have been calling
and begging them to do blip fiction
through flashbacks and Daredevil born
again to the new TVA timeline
destinations in Loki season two I'm
gonna break down the 15 scenes that take
place during the blip in MCU history so
far and why it's now looking likelier
than ever we will finally get some major
context of what really happened during
that time by the way sag capture has
informed us that entertainment
journalists like new rockstars are
allowed to cover movies and TV shows
during the strike but you know what we
stand with the writers and actors on
strike to get the working conditions
they deserve and please subscribe to the
Deep dive for some insane details No One
spotted in Loki's season one and in the
Dark Knight okay in the ncu timeline
thanos's snap occurred in May 2018. do
you know the events Thanos snapped in
wakanda where half of the Avengers there
dusted along with several Heroes on
Titan Nick Fury and Maria Hill vanished
in New York the Barton family dusted in
Missouri Elena Bulova destined students
at Midtown High School tested Hank Janet
and hope Van Dyne dusted half a
everybody dusted in the immediate
aftermath June 2018 Carol Danvers
rejoined The Avengers that was in the
Captain Marvel post credit scene and she
was able to track down Tony Stark and
nebula marooned in space The Avengers
regrouped they located Thanos on the
garden after he destroyed the Infinity
Stones and Thor beheaded in Now Avengers
end game from here jumps five years into
the future showing how the world evolved
and we know what it looks like there
Liberty Island and sitting field were
deserted whales were in the Hudson there
were therapy groups Avengers dealing
with garbage missions and underwater
earthquakes and talking about it on Zoom
calls Clint Barton started killing
cartel guys and Yakuza guys the Starks
moved to a farm Thor was fat and sad and
new Asgard smart Hulk pose of her
selfies and Scott Lang return Thanks to
a rat and inspired the Avengers time I
see yada yada yada but other MCU titles
have indicated another timeline of blip
fiction that went down in these interim
years and I went back through every
recent Marvel title to track down every
single historical noteworthy thing that
happened during those five years and
there are 15 of them and just to cover
our bases here the later seasons of
Agents of Shield do technically take
place during these years but they evolve
some alternate timeline mechanics that
don't really unfold on the same exact
Turf of the blip-stricken Earth in the
way that we're talking about in this
video please watch Agents of Shield it's
so good and at this point the MCU would
just be better off if they just declare
Coulson to be alive canonically and
confirm all of Agents of Shield events
to be MCU Cannon because in my mind they
are they'll just make things better here
are the 15 new MCU blip fiction scenes
as we know them to be starting with mid
to late 2018 t'challa II AKA Tucson is
born in 18. see after t'challa dusted
Nakia pregnant with a shout out at the
time relocated to Haiti and raised to
santere Ryan coogler's original scraper
black panther 2 was going to explore the
timeline during the blip in which
t'challa was dusted and suddenly
returned to find his son being raised by
a stepfather so Tucson spurt very big
deal then fall 2018. Hunter b-15 finds
Rebecca torman a rensslayer's original
pre-tda identity in Fremont Ohio and
Franklin D Roosevelt High School we saw
this in Loki season 1 episode 6 and we
know it was the fall because there were
posters for an upcoming homecoming game
and homecoming is always in the fall
then we're gonna say sometime early in
the blip late 2018 Bruce Banner and Tony
Stark met up in Mexico in a gaming lab
that Tony had built for Bruce as we
learned in She-Hulk episode one but this
is where I spent a blip fixing myself
and integrating the Hulk Banner
identities Tony built it for me a few
years ago Tony Stark we also know that
during this time Bruce and Tony built a
bar and sat around drinking and talking
about Steve Rogers you built this bar
by hand yeah me and Tony
not Tony mostly drank just sat around
like complaining about Steve well it's a
little awkward about this is that based
on Morgan Stark's age in Avengers end
game another significant event late 2018
Morgan Stark would have had to have been
born during this time meaning that Tony
Stark her father was wasting away in
Margaritaville with Bart drunkalo while
his wife had a newborn
now from here we jump ahead to mid-2020
in which Bruce Banner successfully
merged his Hulk identity with his Bruce
Banner identity a process that he said
took 18 months 18 months in a gamma lab
I put the brains and the brawn together
and now look at me
Best of Both Worlds so smart Hulk born
during this time this video is sponsored
by Helix sleep I'm not gonna pretend
like this the first time you've heard me
say that and with good reason I've been
sleeping on a helix mattress for two
years now and it is great it's the best
mattress I've ever owned finding the
perfect mattress can be difficult but
helix's sleep quiz makes it so easy you
just take the quiz and Helix finds a
perfect matches for you I wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool and I got matched with
the dusk Luxe Helix mattress and get
this there's no fiberglass and Helix
mattresses so you won't lose any sleep
over what you're sleeping on Helix
delivers your mattress right to your
door with free shipping in the U.S the
mattress comes rolled up in a box and is
super easy to set up yourself Helix has
a 100 night sleep trial so you get more
than three months to make sure that you
love your mattress Helix mattresses have
a 10-year warranty Helix even offers
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away I love my Helix mattress I
think you would too if you're looking
for a new bed check out Helix sleep
click the link in the description below
or go to helixsleep.com new rockstars to
get 20 off your Helix mattress Plus two
three pillows next we know from set
photos of Daredevil born again that at
least part of that series will take
place in March 2020 in the MCU timeline
with a church sign reading March 15
2020. so Matt Murdoch survived the snap
and spent at least some of the time as
the Dirt Devil vigilante patrolling the
streets of Hell's Kitchen in the MCU
okay next sometime during the blip
shangshi's sister jujai Ling stopped
waiting for shangshi to come back and
left the tin Rings compound to establish
the golden daggers fighting Club in
Macau she told shengchi that she waited
six years which based on that movie's
timeline we went back through it that
would place the golden daggers being
founded in mid-2020. trade is turning to
a week
a week turned to a month and a month
turned to six years which would make
sense that the golden daggers club would
have been built during the blip it kind
of just seems like a blip thing we also
know that there were a series of blip
related tragedies during this time so to
be determined sometime in 2020 Monica
Rambo's Mother Maria Rambo died when her
cancer return according to Dr Harley in
one division episode 4 Maria died three
years
no no which was two years after you
after our wife
after you disappeared and sometime after
Maria Rambo's dead Tyler Hayward took
over sword and suspended the astronaut
program this would also be sometime
mid-2020. I lost half my personal on the
blip and half of those remaining and
lost their nerve the program hasn't been
the same since you've been up there now
also pretty tragic sometimes during the
blitz sometime between 2018 and 2023 Dr
Nick West colleague did Dr Steven
strange while he was is dusted his cats
and his brother died while I was gone I
lost both my cats and my brother and
then also sad but you know less tragic
during the blip also 2018 to 2023 Mr
Harrington morningstar's character from
the Spider-Man home Trilogy he had his
wife fake her dusting and leave him did
I tell you how my wife pretended to blip
out
turns out she ran off with a guy in her
hiking group
we had a fake funeral for her and
everything a little funeral was real
because I thought she was really dead do
you want to see the video no yes there
were other cultural responses to the
blip during this time like a general
resettling around the globe and Refugee
groups like the flag Smashers taking
over new homes San Francisco built a
memorial to the dusted whales returned
to the Hudson and boats moored up to
Liberty Island Kate Bishop was excelling
in her academics her gymnastics and her
fencing during these years and Maya
Lopez Echo grew up age and in the later
years of the blitz Lynn Barton became
the Ronin assassin identity we're gonna
call this mid-2021 Barton killed many
members of the tracksuit Mafia including
Maya Lopez's father which we saw in a
flashback in Hawkeye episode 3. also at
some time during the blip Wong became
sorcerer Supreme and Doctor Strange
instead which we learned about and no
way home the sorcerer's Supreme has
higher duties yes wait I thought you
were the sorcerer's Supreme no he got it
on a technicality because I blipped for
five years oh congratulations and the
latest rumor from the cosmic circus is
that the Loki season 2 scene that is
visible in the trailer set in that
parking lot for piranha power sports
that sells jet skis I think you can see
Mobius in the background there that is
set in Cleveland Ohio one year before
the Battle of Earth and Avengers endgame
which would set this at October 2022 and
it makes sense jet skis that's one way
to relieve stress during an Apocalypse
Now why does it look like both Mobius
and rensslayer were originally normal
folks living during the blip before they
were taken by the TVA was there
something during those blip beers that
made them particularly vulnerable to be
taken by the Kang variant he who remains
well it's worth noting that at least
some of the episodes of Loki season 2
are being directed by Dan W Marvel VFX
supervisor who originally coined the
term the blip and Loki as a time travel
series could take this opportunity to
show us little vignettes of the world
during this dark time both the tragedies
and the victories the heroes and the
villains and the healing and the
relapsing so just to recap some of the
things that happened during that five
years later Gap period of 2018 and 2023
that we don't really talk enough about
the challenge Junior was born rensslayer
worked at a high school star Park and
banner built the gamma lab Morgan Stark
was born smart Hulk was created Matt
Murdock was around the golden daggers
Club was founded Maria Rambo died and
sword shifted its priorities Clinton
Barton pissed off Echo Wong became
sorcerer Supreme and Moby's Soul jet
skis also according to secret Invasion
one million squirrels immigrated to
Earth somewhere in there so my question
for all of you is did Kang allow the
blip to happen so that he could recruit
grief-stricken loners from a forgotten
chapter of history or his Workhorse
comment down below with your thoughts on
this and subscribe to all three channels
of the new rockstars Network you can
follow me on all social platforms at eat
a boss thanks for watching see you next
time bye
[Music]